more legal news a federal judge has
denied Laurie locklins motion to dismiss
all charges in her criminal case in the
ongoing College Admission scandal a
source tells ET the ruling made Laurie
nervous and says the case feels quote
like a bad dream she can't wake up from
more in her fashion designer husband are
accused of paying a half million dollars
to get their daughters into USC by
having them pose as crew recruits real
housewife Lisa Rena joked about it with
her college-age daughter I'm not gonna
put you on a rowing machine and take a
picture of you and say I was the wrong
thing to say I'm trying to get into USC
here I'm like that's not that's just
like joking I would never ever do that I
wouldn't Lori and her husband who have
pled not guilty are set to go on trial
in October and there's a startling new
twist in Vanessa Bryan's wrongful death
lawsuit the brother of the pilot in the
crash just responded ET obtained a copy
of his filing and in it he claims the
Kobe and Gigi quote had knowledge of all
of the particular dangers they were
warned of any potential hazards and they
failed to follow such warnings so the
response by the brother of the pilot
might shock a lot of people what he's
basically saying is that these
passengers including Kobe Bryant took
the risk upon themselves that they
knowingly went on this helicopter
knowing the risk of what could happen I
think it's a it's a tough cling to make
but we'll have to see what kind of
evidence comes forward if this does go
to trial
you